Denn
eine nachhaltige bioökonomie bietet riesige Chancen.
Wir brauchen eine nachhaltige bioökonomie,
um ressourcenschonder
und gleichzeitig ökonomisch erfolgreich
zu wirtschaften.
Wir brauchen eine nachhaltige bioökonomie
als einen wesentlichen Teil
der Transformation unserer Wirtschaft
hin zu Klimaneutralität.
Wir brauchen eine nachhaltige bioökonomie auf dem Weg
zur defacellisierten Wirtschaft,
die uns unabhängiger und krisenresilienter macht.
Wir müssen gleichzeitig aber auch
die Risiken
einer bioökonomischen Transformation identifizieren
und handhaben,
bioökonomie
Fuß auf der Nutzung von nachwachsenden Rohstoffen.
Aber diese Rohstoffe sind zwar,
wie der Name schon sagt, nachwachsend, aber deshalb
noch Lange nicht endlos verfügbar.
Daher brauchen wir einen engen Rahmen,
um zielkonflikte und nutzungskonkurrenzen
zu entkräften.
Diese zielkonflikte
lösen wir
durch gezielte Schließung von stoffkreisläufen
sowie durch einen effizienten
und verringerten Ressourceneinsatz.
Deshalb ist dieser Antrag so wichtig,
weil die schwarz genug zukunftskoalition
die konsequente kreislauffähigkeit
der bioökonomie in den Mittelpunkt stellt.
Denn die bioökonomie ist 1 wesentlicher Teil
der kreisler wirtschaftsstrategie.